this is what we're gonna do here is what
we do I wasn't able to debunk my debunk
[Applause]
[Music]
D but the deep down that was a
compartment earlier you said I was
really practical we were all emo [ __ ]
anal with me in him and you're like hold
on we're touching temp this I initially
I was like practical practical practical
but after listening to everything I
think there is something to what you're
saying and there is in fact I believe in
synchronicity and everything about this
conversation all the dots were connected
in my head okay everything from if there
was you talked about this Mandela effect
yesterday yes and there was a reference
that you made during our discussion and
the uber driver that I rode to take me
to my sister's house made that exact
same obscure reference and I almost
called you and I thought holy [ __ ] of
all the things that this guy could have
said yeah you know he said that thing
that Bobby said yeah another thing of
all the guests that said no to you this
weekend you brought in a guy who is
heavily versed in the Mandela effect yes
so all I'm saying is there is in fact
something that kind of ties this all in
together and as much of as a practical
mind as I have I think there is a deep
connection that we cannot understand
through like scientific explanation do
you think we're in a simulation
[ __ ] you Kennedy what are you talking
about you don't know that no tell me the
theory yeah yeah yeah bro I want to
believe what she's saying it'd be easier
to take the last sweat off give me a
mystery saying I I told my brother I
said at at do part when we're having the
cinnamon roll and thank you
he goes what's wrong with you I go the
reason why this Mandela record thing is
a freak me out is because
I thought I'd died 10 years ago dude do
you just open up with another hour
what are you talking about I think I
died 10 years ago on fountain oh my god
how anybody told me this who car
accident car accident I think that
everything from that death it's my
spirit reliving a continuing to living
am I [ __ ] a ghost I don't know man I
look like my brother was arguing my
brother's like no I'm Bob was crazy yeah
dude but because how I don't know but oh
no this is so awesome
did you plan the talk I got a car
accident fountain right I hit another
actor right god I don't know what actor
it was by for some reason in my mind I
think he's an actor yeah and that I died
instantaneously and then I and I have
this reoccurring image of it you know a
feeling that I did do that like I can
even like you know me and like see the
wreckage and my you know I you know
although all that stuff and then just me
dying but it was a dream or something I
don't know what it is but yeah so I
think shows all this stuff like Trump
and all that so I think I'm imagining
like it's some sort of like alternate
weird thing that's happening but um we
can get that next time I know but here's
it is [ __ ] open up a different
[ __ ] bars well yeah lines awakening
watch West world oh [ __ ] you can it is
it's becoming like it's a pan it's a
bass so you theorists it's similar to
what you're saying that we're we're like
a matrix and we're like tied up to a
theme park
dude it's you have to watch watch world
it's so we saw five episodes we didn't
we stop Oh bro think of the robots being
yourself so they have what their
memories of is just all data
right and they didn't get their hard
drives erased so what's the difference
between humans right now you are having
what's a dream is it a dream or is it
just old hard drives crazy files oh dude
that's my don't even get started on you
start a few hours to our dreams are my
thing I wanted to be like a sleep
scientist so at the end of our podcast
we do it I'm not at the end of the
yellow done at the end of it we do an
hour
[Music]